gilles grévin bon choix
voilà qui à l'âge de 19 ans après avoir
fui le cuba de fidel castro vous
débarquez en france où vous allez
bientôt devenir le disquaire le plus
branché de paris la musique du palace
c'est vous ensuite ce seront les affres
de la solitude et les ténèbres de la
cécité mais aujourd'hui vous revenez
pour nous raconter une époque bénie
[Musique]
et
or comme ans guillermo crievat scarione
absolument vous êtes né le 29 août 1945
à la havane à cuba à l'époque le
dictateur batista est encore au pouvoir
votre père est mécanicien dans votre
père c'était quand même un match au
taciturne un très beau oui ils avaient
les traits un indien un peu oui un peu
et votre mère était blanche elle avait
elle-même une mère française et c'est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement élégant et
raffiné
à la maison on parle pas beaucoup et
tout on écoute la radio en écoute du
tango on écoute de la bossa nova en
écoute des opérettes ce qui fait qu
effectivement vous êtes formé très jeune
à la musique enfants vous êtes très
solitaire ou jouer aux dames dans votre
coin vous aviez peur des autres un peu
oui oui du regard des autres une façon
innée je vois que je tenais pour être
seul je m'intéressais aux chose qui
l'intéressait pas le petit gamin de mon
âge et à l'école vous avez des bonnes
notes mais vous vous levez mélangez pas
aux autres vous préférez la compagnie de
votre maman vous dire j'étais le mari de
ma mère ferland un jour j'aurai jupe de
ma mère ça m'arrangerait bien à la autre
centre d'intérêt glisser la littérature
cette rade culture très très jeune vous
commencé à écrire des nouvelles puis
vous passionner pour chagall ou
passionnés pour soutine vous voyez les
films de la nouvelle vague
d'ailleurs à cuba vous croisé agnès
varda vanessa gred et son mari tony
richardson au très bien leur enseigne
est très jeune vous avez été quand même
attiré par la culture par une digression
culturel de la ville en 1970 15 ans et
vous suivez les cours d'un atelier de
dramaturgie vous fondez avec des amis
maison d'édition vous publier des
nouvelles
et vous découvrez edith piaf à l'époque
alors que la plupart de vos amis rêve
des états unis rêve de new york vous
rêvez de paris ce que je voyais dans le
film
exprès à la havane qui n'est projeté que
tout ce film l'agrochimie à mon amour
les amants jeanne moreau et c'est tout
ce pari tous les premiers films de
truffaut les hôtes se tarit gris où tout
était gris les parapluies noirs tout
j'avais envie des pluies décrit comme
noyé alors sexuellement vous êtes
homosexuel et vous baisez pas beaucoup
en fait je vous avais toujours non je me
sentais coupable un peu j'avais déjà lu
mais ma mère mon père et je ne décroche
jamais en plus c'est en arrivant à paris
on va voir ça plus tard que la fin alors
on va en parler puis suivent est venu
tout terrain surtout
alors qu à l'époque personne ne regrette
le dictateur batista parce que batista
c'était la corruption la prostitution
les casinos donc en castro arrive
évidemment personne ne regrette ce
dictateur inféodés aux gringos américain
au début tout le monde adore castro mais
les choses se gâtent vraiment la peine
de mort est rétablie à des prisonniers
politiques
les traîtres entre guillemets sont
fuselés action ça devrait voir fusillé à
la télé à la whey des gens condamnés
bienfaits à castres on attendait leur
pouvoir les gens qui ont éveillé à la tv
ah oui c'est énorme voilà pierre aussi
il faut le dire des rafles d'homosexuels
qui commence à travers voilà et là vous
décidez donc de quitter cuba vous voulez
devenir ce qu'on appelle c'est très
péjoratif à l'époque on appelle ça un
goût ça non c'est à dire une larve car
les gens qui quittaient le régime
castriste étaient traités de l'arve mais
ça me gêne pas vous avez quand même
envie de partir oui et là miracle
[Musique]
vous rencontrer fidel castro chez sa
maîtresse margarita une actrice
uruguayenne et la scène extraordinaire
si vous êtes chez margarita castro
arrive avec un jambon d'un torchon quand
même
et il arrivait donc voulu parler vous
lui dites voilà j'aimerai bien voyager
et il vous dit appelle incarne ita elle
va s'occuper de toi est en fait vous
avez un cousin qui bosse à l'unesco à
paris qui est prêt non pas vous
accueillir mais ils ont facilité votre
voyage et castro accepte que vous
partiez à paris ce kon extraordinaire et
donc début janvier
1964 vous envoler vers l'europe et vous
arrivez à paris votre cousin qui possède
unesco socrates socrates alors socrates
il est pas super sympa parce qu' il vous
fait poireauter quatre heures dans le
bistrot boulevard gouvion saint cyr
conclu
il vous fait même pas monté chez lui son
clan du tout à la fois reine qu'elle
connaît
et en plus il vous amène non pas chez
lui mais dans un hôtel minable minable
où il a payé la nuit m'a laissé tout
seul avec tous mes doutes avec lui je
regrettais déjà presque plat dans les
piscines à voir oui oui rien de très
important je voudrais juste dire à guy
oui c'est normal qu'ils ne me vois pas
oui et à vous demander pourquoi il imite
l'accent de victoria abril
alors à l'époque vous portez votre
médecin avec nestor almendros c'était la
plus chic et on était dans la merde tous
les deux d'accord vous vous deviendrez
ce que vous êtes devenu mais lui
deviendra le directeur photo de truffaut
de romer de barbet schroeder car bien
évidemment c'est un type extraordinaire
et l'or pour survivre à l'époque où fait
des petits boulots d'être agent de
voyages des manutentionnaires au
printemps vous passez l'aspirateur au
bhv sanaa alors tout va changer lorsque
vous rencontrez cv rossard d'hui donc
qui était éditeur aux éditions du seuil
et y vous trouve un job vous mettez les
livres dans les cartons aux éditions du
seuil
pour les envoyer aux libraires voilà
c'est votre premier boulot dans
l'édition afin et là vous rencontrez
grâce à céder au sort du vault rencontré
roland barthes que vous faites marrer
quoi parce que j'étais très timide
roland bas et vous vous lui faites des
vannes libertines
j'adore mais c'est un dénommé henri
guaino le disquaire d'une boîte qui
s'appelait le fiacre il va vous brancher
dans le métier de dj de disquaires comme
on disait à l'époque
et là vous fréquentez le nuage est alors
au début des années 70 vous devenez le
boute en train du nuage vous commencé à
rencontrer des gens vont lider massimo
gargia ouais
et puis karl lagarfeld et puis kenzo etc
et alors vous vous créez votre style on
va dire que quand vous passez aux
platines vous commencez à imposer le
style très vaste c'est à dire que vous
mélangez tout vous mélangez aussi bien
du rock de l'opérette que dès que des
bruits avec des effets senor vous créé
le style crevasse à ce moment là et le
nuage appartenait à gérald nanty qu on a
tous connu au mathis
des années plus tard et dont on salue la
mémoire
et après gérald nanty donc c'est fabrice
nerfs vous êtes remarqué quand même
partout clé les stars de la nuit
parisienne c'est fabrice et mer qui vous
remarque et vous devenez dj d'une boîte
mémorable rue sainte-anne qui serait le
set qui est une boîte tout petit mais où
il y avait tout le monde là vous croisez
françoise sagan jeanne moreau robert
hirsch
francis bacon saint laurent et bergé et
francis bacon était quand même bien
allumés comme entre l'alcool la cocaïne
il était comme le tout comme les
peintures oui les peintures les pires
est amochée points de suture
et piggy c'est aussi l'époque des top
models oui c'est à dire qu'à l'époque
avec one tous étaient plus belle fille
du monde tout est le 1er mars 1978 il y
à 40 ans fabrice et maire ouvre le
palace
[Musique]
il dépend
je vois la vie
alors je vais dire à stéphane guillon je
n'ai pas les larmes aux yeux
sur commande connard gélard mesure parce
que je suis ému tu verras un jour ça
peut arriver d'être ému tu verras
alors au palace la terre entière s'y
bousculent évidemment karl lagerfeld
salon
merci athens aux mick jagger andy warhol
et ce sont vraiment les dernières fait
que paris a connu parce que depuis
malheureusement il n'y a pas eu beaucoup
de grandes fêtes à paris on regarde le
palace
[Musique]
mais pas
non
[Musique]
c'est la dernière blizzard qu'en voyant
les images ça ne te procure aucune
émotion
en 1980 la fête tire à sa fin
fabrice et mère est malade et non pas du
sida contrairement à ce que tout le
monde raconte maintenant cancer de la
vessie il commence à prendre de la coke
soul influence d'un amant à lui il est
ruiné et arrive le sida la fête est
finie
[Musique]
à
le montois
et voilà c'est la fin de l'insouciance
la fin du libertinage vous partez du
palace qui sur un coup de tête oui sans
fil des minutes et non parce que je
pense que nous sommes une passe à migrer
ensuite vous vous retrouvez aux bains
douches alors effectivement c'est tout à
fait différent c'est le patron du banc
de touche à l'époque c'est pas fabrice
et mer mais bon c'est quand même encore
une bonne époque vous croiser robert de
niro jack nicholson malevolence qu'il
était très sympa vous y resterez
jusqu'en 1990 et c'est là que nous
tournerons bain de minuit
ensemble où chaque semaine depuis une
séquence qui s'appelait le sugar c'est
bien et vous nous disiez les disques
qu'il fallait écouter chaque semaine on
regarde
ce chou à la semaine alors qu'est ce que
c'est
mais pas créer chez habitat ville et
banlieue d'albi ferait ses gains dans la
boue comme susan également que ça va
fonctionner ces pressions
je souhaite qu'on pourra comparer à
peine
certainement mais il habite en
angleterre l'habitat est un jeu de rôles
c'étaient les bains douches c'était bain
de minuit
c'était ma première émission de
télévision ensuite sur le nian sa série
au latino
perdu la vue à ce moment là vous
commencez à commencer et là c'est le
drame
[Musique]
vous dites ma vie a basculé du troisième
étage au quatrième sous-sol oui
c'est le plombier du barrio latino qui
vous dégote à meubler en banlieue à
thiais dans le val-de-marne entier avec
sa série parce que c'est une ville qui
est célèbre pour son cimetière il ya
qu'à ça y'a que ça vous avez quand même
y rester 14 ans guy oui 14 14 ans dans
un petit appartement tout seul vous
écrivez à tout le monde personne vous
réponds je viendrai pas la liste aix de
gens qui m'ont même pas daigné me
répondre que je vous croisez d'avant on
voit la passe oui là c'est la dépression
surtout qu'en plus la justice de la
canne blanche je te pas sûr de moi
j'étais a tant donné je compte en plus
le plafond et comme on ne voit pas alors
tu te mets sur les balcons et c'est très
facile de laisser aller ouais ça a
commencé à mieux aller quand je
découverte par hasard contours ma vie
par un chauffeur taxi
l'association valentin oui je pourrais
citer qui est la principale pour nous
les handicapés visuels ça m'a un peu
commencé
j'y suis il ya valentin whip ya aussi
kenzo oui qu'est exactement celui qui
m'attirait d'élan vital dans un home
studio dans le 16e arrondissement
derrière sur le bien en vie bravo jeu
qui m'a sauvé oui voilà et après ça bon
ben alaya on dirait qu'il ya une
nouvelle vie peut-être que c'est un
tunnel que vous méritez je ne sais pas
mais j'ai pu depuis un an oui tout va
bien tout va bien oui et jean paul goude
a dit que vous portiez très bien la
canne blanche c'est vrai j'ai c'est
merci
tu me vois sur yon oui vous êtes très
bien ça se ressent j'avais plaisir de
voir
[Applaudissements]
hier
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu